we use the word economy to summarize
what is literally billions of things
billions of people making billions of
decisions all connected to each other
and yet the result of all of these
decisions is one of two things this line
either going up or going down
this all-encompassing number on a graph
is called the gross domestic product GDP
which by the way is kind of the most
undescriptive useless title ever given
to anything GDP is like the receipt of
an economy every single thing that was
made and sold in an economy all added up
into one giant number just imagine every
TV and piano lesson and slice of pizza
and car wash and pair of shoes and
smartphone and video games everything
that the people purchased from the
businesses in your economy in one year
all added up and packed into this one
dot and plopped on a graph
[Music]